[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Priya
Natarajan who is professor of astronomy
and physics at Yale she is a theoretical
astrophysicist interested in cosmology
gravitational lensing and black hole
physics her research and original
contributions to the study of dark
matter dark energy and black holes have
won her many awards and honors including
election to the fellowship of the
American Physical Society and Guggenheim
and Radcliffe fellowships today we'll
speak with professor Natarajan about her
book mapping the heavens the radical
scientific ideas that reveal the cosmos
which was awarded the Gustav Ranas
International Book Prize by the
Macmillan Center this year
welcome professor Natarajan thank you so
much so delighted to be here so let's
talk about your book I'm very excited
let's start with an overview so the book
chronicles the acceptance of radical
scientific ideas in cosmology over the
last hundred years and the reason for
choosing the past hundred years is that
there have been very transformative
ideas that have been proposed new
technologies that have enabled us to
probe the cosmos better and so I wanted
to showcase how our cosmic understanding
has so dramatically evolved transforming
our cosmic view as well as our place in
the cosmos so what led you to write the
book so you know I've always been
interested in writing because there is a
process of clarification of ideas that
happens even as a scientist when you
write a science scientific paper and I
also have a checkered history in the
sense that I have an unfinished PhD in
the history and philosophy of science so
always been interested in sort of the
deeper processes by which we generate
knowledge and how that knowledge gets
tested and verified and cosmology is a
very interesting discipline so it's one
of those few disciplines where we cannot
perform controlled experiments because
you know the cosmos is what it is a
supernova goes off here you can't make
it go off there tomorrow and make it
repeat so you have the cosmos and you
can't perform any kind of controlled
experiments that's a challenge then to
validate a theory or a model and the
solution that the field has arrived at
is that you perform these very large
scale simulations so simulations of a
chunk of the universe and you start off
with a theoretical understanding and you
see how it evolves in time and see if
any slice of it corresponds to slices
that you actually observe in the
universe so I was interested in
epistemically in this process of how you
generate new knowledge in a feel like
cosmology where you can't do experiments
so that was what I was gonna work on
right so that has always been in the
back of my mind and so as my career
progressed and I was working on these
are the four front areas and you know
myself I had these experiences of
proposing new ideas and you know feeling
the push back and then eventually seeing
how those ideas get accepted you know
it's really fortunate at this time right
that in one lifetime of a scientist you
can actually propose an idea and they
can test it and it can be validated or
invalidating so during the course of my
work I realized that I have some
interesting insights as an insider on
this process and that I would like to
share ok let's talk about you pick a
torso of these transformational events
or discovery so tell us about some of
them and then talk about the process of
them coming to be accepted so I think I
start the book out with what I think was
the most rad
call shift that happened and that was
the discovery of the expansion of the
universe by the astronomer Edwin Hubble
till then this is about early 1900s or
1920 in the 1920s and till then we
believed that the cosmos was static it
was unchanging and it was fixed and his
discovery of the expansion of the
universe completely upended our notion
it was very disorienting discovery and
he used this the speeds of nearby stars
that he measured to infer this expansion
history and the process was complicated
most astronomers found his evidence
convincing and his argument but Einstein
who actually had a theory of cosmology
proposed the theory of general
relativity had been proposed and it gave
a very good description of the evolution
of the cosmos and he did not like it
because he was emotionally wedded to the
idea of a fixed universe so he pushed
back in fact he went back and he
tinkered with his equations to stop the
universe from having a solution and
expanding solution so in the book I
recount this tension and the back and
forth and Einstein desperately trying to
recover a static universe and failing
because the data was just starting to
accumulate and eventually and this is
what is so beautiful about science right
not only that Einstein changed his mind
I mean it was noted when he changed his
mind in a seminar he finally said okay I
believe that's right he actually very
promptly started working on the
expanding model of the universe so I
wanted to sort of illustrate that whole
circle so you can have someone who is
very skeptical and that's part of being
having a scientific mind but then when
the data gets overwhelming you have to
change your mind and then you know he
starts working on it trying to
understand it at a deeper level so
that's one of the first ideas that I
discuss in the book and of course rather
close to my heart or this sort of
subfields that I work in so the idea of
black holes yes and the idea of black
holes is really
article and the reason for that is that
no one believed they were actually real
they were actually mathematical
solutions to Einstein's equation once
again and so these are basically
Einstein's equations tell you the
relationship between matter and the
shape of space and black holes tend to
be these very compact objects which have
extremely pinched shape the space shape
of space so they have a singularity
they're very peculiar mathematical
property nobody thought that nature
would actually produce such objects so
this would have to be objects that are
so dense and so compact that the gravity
around would be so intense that not even
light can escape so this was a
mathematical idea no one thought it was
gonna be real actually the Indian
astrophysicist subramanyam's Chandra
Shekar worked out that the end state of
very very massive stars when they die
they have a very explosive death in the
end they leave behind this very very
compact object which really looks like a
black hole that looks like the black
hole solution so once again you know his
very own mentor in Cambridge Arthur
Eddington was very established figure in
astrophysics did not like this solution
and pushed back and so you know there
was a very complicated emotional
encounter public encounter when they
debated and then you know Chandra
actually Chandra Shekar is known as
Chandra actually left England he's moved
his entire career to the United States
and settled down in Chicago and it was
not until World War two when people were
actually able to with the first
computers compute the problem of
explosions and they realized in a
different context of course and they
realized the same problem as X stellar
explosions that they were able to arrive
at this black hole solution so you know
it took a long time
you know 30s to about 50 s sort of 20-30
years before the possibility of black
holes becoming real happen however the
discovery of an actual object
that had the properties of a black hole
especially supermassive black holes
these are black holes are about a
million times the mass of the Sun like
the one lurking silently in the center
of our own galaxy in the Milky Way and
these black holes when they're actively
growing are glowing because of the gas
that is falling into the black hole the
black hole itself doesn't produce light
because it actually absorbs any and all
the light that strays nearby but gas
that is getting sucked in by the black
hole the dying gasps the glass and the
gas is glowing and so you detect these
objects as quasars and the first quasars
they're sort of cosmic beacons very very
bright and they were detected 1960s so
it took almost 30 40 years for this idea
to be accepted and it's one of the
strange ideas because it started life
not as a physical object but a
mathematical entity and then you were
able to go and find the corresponding
physical object that had those
properties and then the other idea again
related to the field that I work in is
dark matter which is sort of different
where dark matter was detected
observationally we did not have a
theoretical framework or any
mathematical description what's the
difference between dark matter and a
black hole so a dark matter is
gravitating matter that is present
everywhere in the universe it's smeared
lightly pretty much everywhere like jam
on toast everywhere in the universe but
there are regions in the universe where
it's really lumped and it's lumped
around where you have light so galaxies
so galaxies appear to have from the
evidence that we have so far extended
distributions of dark matter that go
well beyond the light in the stars that
we see so black holes are extremely
compact objects we don't know what dark
matter is made of but whatever it is
made of allows it to be spread out
everywhere whereas black holes are
really compact and they sink to the
Centers of galaxies wow that's
fascinating I'm curious to know how you
did your research for the book
and and actually how you went about
choosing the eight or so discoveries
that you did so I think that you know
the the shape of the book evolved over
time so one of the sort of enduring
interest that I've had since I was a
young girl is maps and so on this idea
of mapping and this relationship of
between mapping and knowing when we can
map something the fact that we know it
and so originally I thought I would
because my own research work involves
mapping this dark matter that is smeared
everywhere from the deflection and the
impact on light that this dark matter
produces phenomenon of gravitational
lensing and you know I I thought I would
be writing a book that would be much
more focused on mapping and but then I
realized and you know in all these
radical ideas that I talked about
they're all centered around mapping they
all centered around observing because
astronomy such a visual observational in
driven science that they all had aspects
of mapping on them right I mean sort of
very part and parcel of the idea so I
think picking these eight ideas was
actually not difficult at all I think
there's enormous scientific consensus in
our community that these have been the
most impactful radical ideas that have
transformed our cosmic perspective and
then how did you go about basically
doing the research around each of them I
mean because you know when I read the
part about Einstein finally acquiescing
and saying okay it looks like you are
right about this and Hubble sounds like
just such a fascinating individual how
did you do the research around all of
the people in the book so because you
know I am interested in the psychology
of science I tend to read a lot about
you know scientific memoirs as well as
biographies and autobiographies so you
know over the years I was reading and I
had sort of you know made a note of
these interesting individuals that so
when I sat down to write the book they
were on
of sources and there's also it's a very
rich genre it's a lot of astronomers and
astrophysics lots of science writers
have written excellent books as well so
there were many many sources but I tried
for every chapter I tried to find a
couple of really original sources so I
dig a dug into archives and what is very
fortunate today right you can be an
armchair archivist everything is scanned
everything pretty much is available
online but you know I I made sure that
other than the secondary sources that I
used that I always dug and looked for
something new particularly about the
people and the controversies and really
about trying to read letters so I read a
lot of letters to try and understand the
you know sort of - unsorted entangle the
intellectual part of the controversies
from the personal ambition from you know
all the other emotional human things
that were tied into it so I really
wanted to write a book that was very
different in this way from all the other
books that are there it's not entirely
focused on the personalities but the
human side of the personalities and the
intellectual work of those personalities
is really there and of course the
technologies so I am also interested you
know as I said in the history of science
and technology so the history of the
evolution of astrophotography and you
know computing and how that sort of has
really helped the growth the you know it
has really impacted they have not been
just mere tools they've been more than
tools so they've been very intricately
wrapped in with the ideas itself because
they actually help you forge new
directions for exploration so I think
sort of you know looking at archives
letters and second resources and of
course you know one of the things that I
do is for each of these ideas I try to
bring the reader up to date to today so
I give you a status update and that was
you know easy to do because I'm really
active in the field and that was a real
fun and joy to write and I really
enjoyed that process of starting sort of
historically and of having a nonlinear
narrative and yet coming full circle and
showing where we are today
and how we got there when you were doing
the archive work in reading the letters
and trying to find new pieces of
information did you come across anything
that said hey wow I didn't know this or
kind of surprised you I think the thing
that was most surprising to me was the
discovery of a map it was I thought I
was really i knew my maps and in
particular right I was interested both
in celestial and terrestrial maps so I
think what was really surprising for me
was this find of a map by Abraham
kreskis he was a catalan in 13 14th
century and what was interesting about
that map of the cosmos you know
obviously this was imagined cosmos so it
was a little bit of observational data
as all naked eye astronomy of course at
that point and then there was a lot of
myth there was a lot of imagination rich
imagination what time period over 1300
1300 and just the stunning rendition of
this map in colors and there was a major
shift in his maps compared to maps from
even fifty years before and the shift
was that there was an astrolabe in the
center of the map rather than a godly
figure so you know without reading too
much into it I think that there was a
way in which he was able to see or he
captured sort of the potential of what
instruments were going to do and the
role that they would play in sort of
transforming this map so that was for me
an amazing fine because it encoded an
Intel
actual shift of perspective that was
subtle but very impactful pretty
visionary for the time I would imagine
yeah yeah so as a scientist you are
basically exploring the final frontier
being space so I'm I'm curious to know
if there's something that you could
discover what would you hope it to be
well you know just after finishing to
tell you that you know scientists are
obviously emotionally attached to their
ideas they shouldn't be but you know try
not to be so I think there are two
things one is in a very near term and
one is likely longer term that I would
love to see detected and discovered in
the cosmos because I've kind of worked
on this one is I know I've worked on a
potential new way to make the first
black holes so traditionally black holes
are expected tiny black holes are left
as remnants of stars but they're too
tiny to really explain how they could
account for the supermassive black holes
that inhabit the centres of most if not
all galaxies and we believe that these
black holes could have formed need to
have formed very very early on in the
universe because we're detecting these
quasars that are powered by the
supermassive black holes further and
further back in time and so the black
holes that power these are about a
million times the mass of the Sun and
you need such a big black hole to have
formed when very few large galaxies have
formed right so very few massive things
in the universe have formed and so we
proposed an AI this channel to form the
first black hole which is called direct
collapse black holes in which you bypass
the formation of a star and a lot of gas
just condenses it's rather like the
vortex when you pull the plug in your
bathtub the way the water rushes in
something similar to that happens in the
very early universe with gas and gas
gets funneled in and forms a black hole
so this picture
idea was we proposed at about 15 years
ago and you know we've been working on
it developing it and providing
observational signatures calculating
them in the James Webb Space Telescope
which was due to fly this month and has
been delayed for two years is poised to
discover them if they're out there so I
think in the near term in the next two
to three years when this telescope flies
I would be thrilled if these objects
were discovered of course I mean it
would be great either way but you know I
would be really thrilled if these red
claps black holes are actually found and
I think that they have very clear
signatures and so we will be able to
discriminate them if we find them so
that's the narottam and the longer term
is of course you know the collisions of
stellar-mass black holes these tiny
black holes was discovered by the LIGO
collaboration so the sort of earthquakes
in space-time that were detected
gravitational waves were detected by the
LIGO collaboration they were awarded the
Nobel Prize last year but you know these
are the little cousins of the black
holes that I really like the
supermassive ones they also collide in
the universe and to detect the waves the
gravitational waves that are produced
due to their collision you actually need
the kind of a paradis you had on the
ground here in space so that's another
Space Telescope called Lisa
it's a project I'm involved in on the
NASA Lisa team and that you know is
proposed to fly in the 2030s and they
will discover so this instrument will
discover the first gravitational wave
output from colliding supermassive black
holes I would love to see that I've
worked on various aspects of you know
what else you could see along with
gravitational waves from these black
holes so and you know of course there's
always this big open question right the
nature of dark matter it would be
awesome if there was some discovery of
the particle some hint even a small hint
of what that particle might be because
we know so much about how the dark
matter is distributed
how it clumps and you know how it
evolves over time and it's in the
driving seat of everything we know in
cosmology but the particle remains
elusive said that would be a very nice
discovery you know I always say maybe in
the next five years and I think we have
to be optimistic because with science
you never know you could never predict
the future course of science right I
mean these this team the LIGO team that
detected gravitational waves the first
detection they'd been working for 40
years right so let's hope it's not
another 40 year ice but we should be
pushing it for me but it would be
fabulous if you know these three things
got found illuminated understood in my
lifetime right well this has been
fascinating for me thank you so much for
being here today and sharing your work
thank you so much for having me for more
information about professor nutty Jean
and her research please visit our
website at macmillan report yale.edu be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the Macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale
you